we must mention viola the next project
you are playing another real person
uh slightly more famous
share with the group who you're going to
be michelle obama
and i wish that somebody had taken me
aside when i thought about that and said
okay
now kyle let me give you let's have a
little bit of
vodka and really think about this
because people love
michelle obama they feel like they know
her they
own her they and
they don't want anything that's negative
to
touch her now as an actor you're like
okay where's the mess
we had the complexity how am i gonna do
that with michelle obama
but you i'm not gonna do that has she
given you her blessing
oh yeah she's listen everything you
think feel see with michelle obama is
all that she is
okay we know that but i always say
you could talk to my husband you could
talk to my daughter
you could talk to my mom about me if
someone were gonna play me in a biopic
but you would still only know 40 or 50
of me
you could not get to know some deep dark
secrets that i wouldn't even share with
the people who are closest to me
and it's all that info that you gather
as an actor to create another human
being
so now i got michelle obama what do i do
with it i mean
i mean what do i do with that i mean she
didn't kill her husband you know he's
still very much alive
yes yes
you